on va jouer aux cabines à bernard les
cabines à berne house avec bernard
montiel c'est eux massés 24 heures d'une
journée
il passe 20 heures dans des cabines à uv
mp voilà j'ai toujours bien toujours
beau alors un chéri ça va être très
simple
bernard tu vas aller avec eux sur scène
d'accord et on va vous poser des
questions ou la très simple les deux
vous allez vous affrontez pas bien avec
moi miss monde miss monde où elle peut
s'il vient vers moi et me demandez pas
rare qu'elles montent à l'esca beau
marais merci balisé avec miss monde
merci les cabines à bernard s'est tout
de suite c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
c'est simple on va jouer avec les
téléspectateurs et on va jouer avait un
vidéo gag bernard montiel a été le
présentateur de vidéo gag pendant des
années oui donc voyons avec des vidéos
du lac tour à 12 tours à tous je vous
montrer des vidéos vous allez devoir
retrouver la suite caroline et mathieu
si vous trouvez la bonne réponse on
versera de la crème solaire sur le
voisin si c'est la mauvaise réponse
c'est vous qui recevraient la crème
solaire celui qui aura marqué le plus de
points et reçu le moins de crème solaire
ira en laponie d'accord et remplacera
bernard en cas d'égalité du reich
question bien sûr qu'on n'a pas une
question subsidiaire à caroline voici la
première question
une femme participe un spectacle de
dauphins regarder et essayer de trouver
quelle est la suite c'est parti
[Musique]
ce qu'on peut enlever la clé mecheri
parce que je suis au bout du rouleau ça
des gens laponie alors pourquoi la sur
le dauphin va prendre la jeune fille
pour sa femme
le dauphin va injecter la jeune fille or
le dauphin va mettre un gilet jaune et
se mettre en grève le regarde cet
arrivage hiver très bonnes réponses
les turbines en cas d appoint la passion
matthieu delormeau regardez cette vidéo
d'un enfant en train de chanter du
whitney houston voilà alors que va-t-il
se passer
sa soeur à l'intervention la jeune fille
va légèrement s'énerver il s'agit une
nouvelle fois de bouder qui nous bloque
la hune sa soeur va interrompre la deux
la jeune fille va légèrement s'énerver
regarde la fin sans énerver way s'est
énervé tout simplement caroline dans
cette vidéo va faire un petit retour en
arrière vous rappelez du ice bouquet
challenge regardez cette jeune
américaine s'apprête en ferrain alors
que va-t-il se passer
un oiseau va gâcher ce moment la jeune
fille ne va recevoir ne va pas recevoir
que de l'eau malheureusement ou ne pas
pour ne pas qu'elle soit mouillé gilles
verdez va la protéger
bayer comme ça c'est la vie à deux là
deux jeunes femmes ne suis pas sur scène
mathieu garon
on part dans un spectacle de danse vous
aimez la danse j'adore me regarde
[Musique]
alors que va-t-il se passer de danseurs
on s'embrouille et une personne du
public valeur lancé une chaussure ou la
scène va péter comme benjamin castaldi
c'est la 3 baby la 308 connaître
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la question subsidiaire
voilà là j'aurais bien mis à molines
benjamin voici la question pour vous
départager
non monsieur tient que vont demeurer
servir et à dieu ce n'est pas la même
carrière c'est vrai benjamin et bien
d'autres voici la question pour vous
départager par la route
combien y at-il de kilomètres entre le
studio de tpm paix et le village du père
noël en laponie boulot
matthieu delormeau absolument aller
mathieu allawi vous n'êtes pas allé 4712
km 4712 km carreaux 3000km arrête je
vous le dis celui qui sera le plus
proche gagnera son billet pour la
laponie 1 la distance entre le studio
tpm pee wee et la laponie dieu le plus
proche oui
non c'est de tout changer cela les
personnes changent le personnes changent
c'est terminé on n'est pas et on est et
on n'est pas au souk ici les profs de
volée phrase de prost et yoann on n'est
pas au souk à bebela vieux quoi qu'ils
allaient gérer vous savez combien 4000
4712 et vous 3000 milles 1 la bonne
distance et de tarot 3011 km c'est 40
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci bernard mathieu vous allez nous
allons vous nettoyez et dans un instant
j'aurais peut-être un truc à vous dire
que je suis en tête d'abord une idée
absolument aller mes racines matthieu
delormeau risque
[Applaudissements]